the monster verse of the production
company a legendary and it seems to get
a new edition soon however the setting
will no longer be a large metropolis or
an island but the snowy landscape of
North America of course we are talking
about the mystical creature Bigfoot at
least that's what the Hollywood Reporter
reports who also found out that the
studio supposed to have secured the
rights to Max Brooks novel devolution
allegedly Brooks who also wrote the
template for world wars he had already
developed a concept for Bigfoot movie in
24 then decided to write the book
template first the story of devolution
revolves around a small village in the
US state of Washington it's located at
the bottom of the huge volcano Mount
Rainier and is attacked by a monster
after his eruption the locals also call
it sasquatch which means hairy giant the
villager Kate Hollen is at the center of
the story according to the sources of
The Hollywood Reporter the plot will be
mixture of a survival brutal horror and
scientific investigation the border
between truth and fiction shall be
closed together but if devolution really
makes it into the monster verse at the
end of the day is still questionable
legendary Studios have secured the
rights however it is hard to imagine
Bigfoot next to Godzilla and Kong a
seamless connection to the sagas
therefore difficult nevertheless we want
to let us be surprised how the studio
plans the realization of the novel a
release date is not foreseeable at this
time the shooting of Jurassic world 3
has been on hold for months as deadline
on reports the casted film crew will
continue shooting the blockbuster and
his strict conditions on July 6th this
will be the first major film project to
actually start production again in the
UK the reason for this is a
comprehensively worked out security
concept that Universal presented for the
shooting at the Pinewood Studios in
London in addition to the immense losses
that Universal is suffering with every
day that production comes to a
standstill the film studio has invested
another 5 million u.s. dollars just for
the implementation of the concept this
includes the installation of the private
medical facility called your doctor and
strict instructions a part of this is
regular testing on the sent the
immediate isolation of employees with
clear symptoms as so-called anti virus
[ __ ] that is sprayed on the set at night
countless disinfectant dispensers and of
course the obligatory wearing of masks
however this shouldn't have that much of
a
fact on this scenes in front of the
camera as most of the scenes with lots
of people and if pile have already been
shot they're responsible people have so
far health unto their cinema release on
the 11th of June 2021 well the quick and
strict implementation of Universal
requirements will also have a positive
impact on the Batman or fantastic beast
3 which also filmed in England will
certainly be seen soon due to the
pandemic the San Diego comic-con cannot
take place at the end of July as usual
and can be therefore comfortably watched
from home through a small event DC and
Warner Brothers probably thought that
this was not a bad idea and announced
the DC fandom event a few days ago the
whole thing is supposed to take place in
August 22nd and last 24 hours
casual talks with the creative minds
behind films like the Batman Wonder
Woman 1984 or the Suicide Squad a
planned Zack Snyder is also supposed to
have been specially invited to chat
about this long way to Justice League
Snyder cut so far the rock has also
announced this appearance on Instagram
also included is the cast off of the
Suicide Squad with its director James
Gunn and many more will probably follow
the whole thing is conceived is a
participatory event for fans around the
globe because as a viewer you also have
the opportunity to actively participate
in the DC fandom by submitting creative
work actually a cool idea it'll be
interesting to see how the whole thing
will be implemented what do you think we
can expect from the DC fandom maybe new
trailer for Wonder Woman 1984 or first
Victoria likes herbs for the upcoming
the Batman ride it in the comments and
once again a wave of postponement of
cinema releases is passing through
Hollywood
the first one is Christopher Nolan's
Tennant who stuck to his release until
the end however the new date is also
just two weeks later as the new date for
the US market is 31st of July 2020
Wonder Woman 1984 is also affected by
the postponements in this case Warner
Brothers agreed on release on October
2nd in phase of the already 4th
postponement of Wonder Woman 1984
leading actress gal gadot now turned to
a fans via Twitter thanked them for
their support so far and promised that a
long wait would be worth it one of the
few good news is from James Bond no time
to die because here fans can at least
look forward to an earlier release on
November 20th 2020
the following changes only affect the US
market so far matrix 4 which is now
dated on April 1st 2022 the originally
planned time slot of matrix 4 on May
21st 2021 will be given to a completely
different film named Liga Silla forces
come Universal is also tackling some
movies Tom Hanks science fiction film
buyers is postponed by half a year to
April 16 2021 Keanu Reeves bill and tad
face the music even slides a bit forward
and will now be released on August 14th
2020 another shift that directly affects
the film world is the rescheduling of
the 2021 Academy Awards which used to
take place in February after the gold
Globes but next year this will change
instead of the 20th of February the
presentation of the world's most
important film price will now take place
on 25th of April 20-21
the main reason for this is not even
just the distance relations much more
far-reaching problems for one thing many
films that are considered candidates for
the film award are still stuck in
post-production and it's not yet clear
how many can be completed by the end of
the qualification phase of course one
factor is that the longer you wait the
more likely you are to have fewer
restrictions for the ceremony finally
the planned completion of a 400 million
u.s. dollar film museum is currently not
possible due to the pandemic it was
actually planned to inaugurate the
museum at the same time as the Oscar
ceremony this would already be the
fourth relocation in the history of the
Academy Awards because so far only a
flood in Los Angeles in the 1930s the
assassination of Martin Luther King jr.
and an assassination attempt on u.s.
President Ronald Reagan could prevent
the prestigious award ceremony from
taking place on the planned date
[Music]